vous dites en parlant du rap inciter au
meurtre des flics en insultant sa mère
c'est immonde et même la ségrégation
raciale n'a jamais suscité de telles
chansons
alors Ray Charles vous êtes né en 1930
en Géorgie ce qui explique sans doute la
chanson Georgia my mind dans une famille
très pauvre père absent parce qu'il
travaillait sur le réseau ferroviaire et
votre mère vous élève avec la première
femme de son mari
comment est-ce possible c'est très rare
ça quand même que deux femmes qui ont
été mariées avec le même homme
acceptent d'élever un enfant ensemble
et bien sûr
j'ai eu de la chance
bien sûr ma mère était toujours la plus
la personne la plus importante c'était
la chef mais l'autre dame elle m'aimait
parce que elle n'avait pas d'enfant et
donc je suis devenu numéro 1 sur sa vie
donc c'était très agréable pour moi je
dois admettre parce que Notre-Dame
lorsque j'avais des ennuis et
l'empêchait ma mère de me frapper
alors c'est extraordinaire c'est qu'il y
en a une que Ray Charles s'appelait Mama
et l'autre il l'appelait mother voilà
comment ça se passait alors Rey dès
l'âge de 3 ans un voisin vous apprend à
jouer du piano des mélodies avec un seul
doigt et c'est comme ça que vous
découvrez la musique
merveilleux parce que
il devait savoir qu'il y avait quelque
chose à l'intérieur de moi parce que il
aurait pu facilement dire éloignez-vous
de moi
petit gamin de m'entraîner mais il a dit
non cet enfant et bien il a tout arrêté
pour entendre cette musique et c'est
comme cela que il a commencé à
m'apprendre à jouer avec un seul doigt
alors à l'âge de 5 ans vous vivez Ray
Charles le premier dame de votre vie
votre frère se noie devant vos yeux dans
un baquet plein d'eau pendant que votre
mère repasse et comme les vêtements de
votre frère sont gorgés d'eau vous êtes
incapable de le ressortir du baquet
est-ce que c'est ce traumatisme qui a
commencé à vous faire perdre la vue
je pense pas que vous si important
perdre mon frère c'était une chose peut
être ma vue c'était tout à fait
différent c'était pas lié tout ça
je pense que le glaucome était
responsable de la perte de ma vue la
mort demande frère et bien
j'en ai souffert pendant de nombreuses
années parce que je me suis sentie
respectable j'ai fait la pression que je
retire pouvoir le sauver donc il a fallu
longtemps pour que je puisse récupérer
mais le glaucome est bien c'était
responsable de ma cécité alors à ce
temps vous avez définitivement perdu la
vue et votre mère vous y avez préparé
parce que ça a pris un certain nombre de
mois et votre mère vous avez préparé et
elle vous disait Rey tu es aveugle tu
n'es pas idiot
et elle comprend très bien votre mère
que votre salut passe par votre
autonomie et elle vous apprend pendant
toute cette période de perte de vue elle
vous apprend les gestes courants pour un
aveugle
tout à fait
je sais pas comment elle était si
intelligente
une si grande perception mais vous savez
tout à fait raison ma mère
elle m'a appris
elle m'a préparé pour cette fille je
deviendrai aveugle elle a mis l'accent
sur le fait que écoute il faut apprendre
comment survivre et tout ça et elle m'a
toujours dit
qu'il y a toujours deux façons de faire
tout il faut trouver simplement la bonne
façon pour toi
alors là vous êtes placé dans un
établissement pour aveugle et sourd vous
êtes pensionnaire et si une école assez
étrange parce que on sépare dans cette
école les sourds et les aveugles les
garçons et les filles il est blanc et
les Noirs alors que tout le monde est
aveugle donc il y a pas de raison de
séparer les blancs et les noirs
[Rires]
je me suis posé cette question pendant
toute ma vie et je ne comprends toujours
pas
c'était comme ça c'était comme ça
alors jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans dans cette
école vous étudiez le Drive vous
apprenez à écrire le braille à lire le
braille vous apprenez la musique vous
êtes influencé par des gens comme
artatum artichaut mais aussi des gens
comme Chopin sibérieuses Mozart alors
c'est l'époque où vous composez vos
premiers morceaux vous créez un
orchestre qui s'appelle de Shop Boys
vous êtes dingue de musique à cette
époque mais autre drame dans votre vie
en 1945 vous avez 15 ans et là votre
mère meurt vous êtes incapable de manger
vous êtes incapable de dormir et vous
êtes même incapable de pleurer et vous
allez voir une vieille femme qui
s'appelle ma bec et cette vieille femme
on disait si le paradis existe elle doit
vraiment y aller parce qu'elle le mérite
et ma bec vous aide à ne plus vous
sentir coupable de la mort de votre
frère et de la mort de votre mère
comme vous dites et bien
tout arrangé dans ma vie en fait c'est
qu'elle a fait c'est que elle m'a fait
pleurer
et c'était pour la première fois je n'ai
pas pu pleurer après la mort de ma mère
parce qu'elle m'a dit une chose toute
simple
c'est comme ça qu'elle s'appelait
et bien est-ce que tu penses que c'est
ce qu'elle veut que tu fasses
continuer même après son départ l'espace
qu'elle t'a toujours dit comment
oui oui
alors là vous sortez de la dépression
et à 15 ans vous quittez cette
institution vous commencez à jouer dans
des clubs et c'est une période difficile
pour vous vous mangez souvent des des
sardines des haricots secs du pain
période extrêmement difficile pour vous
et en 1947 à l'âge de 17 ans vous vous
installez à Seattle et là vous
rencontrez quicks in Jones et deux ans
plus tard en 1949 vous faites votre
premier disque
exactement
tout ça c'est vrai
on travaillait dans un club à siècle qui
s'appelle la loi qui
avait des jeux d'argent
à l'étage
et puis il a commencé à écouter mon trio
et il est venu me voir m'a dit écoute
quand même est-ce que tu aimerais faire
un disque et bien sûr
ah oui je t'ai excité ouais ah ouais je
vais pouvoir faire mon premier disque et
je ne connaissais rien à l'aspect argent
je m'en foutais je voulais simplement
faire un disque
et en 49 c'est là où j'ai fait mon
premier disque qui s'appelait the
fashion blues et voilà et ce n'est qu'à
l'âge de 24 ans en 1954
l'année où pour vous c'est si terrible
Serge Lama l'année de l'hiver froide 54
quand votre père arrête de chanter que
vous enregistrez Agathe woman alors il y
a ce soir sur le plateau avec nous Ray
Charles un garçon qui était un
réalisateur qui vient de faire son
premier film qui a beaucoup de succès
qui s'appelle Yvan Attal et Yvan Attal a
voulu un tituler son premier
court-métrage I got a woman et il est là
ce soir il vous regarde il vous admire
beaucoup
lui aussi génial
alors
vous avez vous avez eu pendant votre
carrière à faire face à Elvis Presley et
ensuite au Beatles ça pas été facile
pour vous
rester soi-même en permanence
pour nous enfin pour la musique et
surtout des Beatles en particulier
j'étais un grand
fans
des Beatles vous avez repris Elena rugby
j'ai repris yesterday de John Lennon
nous avait repris imagine en revanche
vous êtes beaucoup moins moins fan
beaucoup moins fan du rap et vous dites
en parlant du rap inciter au meurtre des
flics en insultant sa mère c'est immonde
et même la ségrégation raciale n'a
jamais suscité de telles chansons
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'il faut commencer avec les
sociétés qui fabriquaient que ce sont
ces personnes-là qui n'ont ces produits
mais pour moi la musique jamais dû être
quelque chose de sale
d'amour et quelque chose
comme à la musique
peut-être
sa mère ou sa fille
je ne comprends pas ça je ne comprends
pas à mon avis
cela n'a pas de place dans la musique un
point c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
vous avez eu des petits problèmes avec
la drogue vous avez été arrêté en 1961
et puis après en 1962 en possession
d'héroïne et vous avez déclaré je me
drogue depuis l'âge de 16 ans ne croyez
pas que j'aime ce genre de saloperie
mais j'en ai besoin ensuite j'ai fait
une cure de désintoxication et vous avez
arrêté la drogue depuis cette époque
est-ce que vous avez vraiment arrêté
question intéressante
[Applaudissements]
vous posez la question sur le cabanisme
et fumer si vous dit vous voulez dire
qu'on fume du cannabis ici tout le monde
en fume là ne vous en faites pas
Los Angeles votre bureau est un immeuble
sans fenêtre et dans à l'intérieur de
cet immeuble on doit rien toucher parce
que vous savez exactement où chaque
chose se trouve c'est à dire que vous
avez un petit peu la vision au bout des
doigts
à l'intérieur donc c'est naturellement
ou tout se trouve
parce que c'est danger
donc c'est très facile
j'ai la chance d'avoir ce dont j'ai
besoin pour vivre alors votre force
effectivement c'est cette vision au bout
des doigts et aussi vos oreilles votre
oui on vous appelle bayonic hier ce qui
veut dire l'oreille bionique vous avez
l'oreille absolue et vous dites mes
oreilles me disent 99% de ce que je dois
savoir sur ce qui m'entoure
ï et c'est pour ça que vous financez des
associations qui s'occupent de d'opérer
les oreilles
yes
j'ai une fondation et ce que nous
faisons
des enfants qui n'ont jamais rien
entendu de leur vie bien merci vous avez
une question à poser à Ray Charles
Sylvain non il faudrait juste dire à
quel point je suis ému de le voir de je
trouve que c'est la grande classe
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
le pire est à venir le pire estavenu
nous allons faire une interview
upendown
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que préférez-vous en vous
que je préfère
la perfection on peut jamais
à tout moment voilà qu'est-ce que vous
détestez en vous
s'il y a quelque chose dans ma vie
honnêtement je dirais que je déteste
cette chose parce que j'ai appris à
surmonter la plupart des choses qui
poussent un problème pour moi
qu'est-ce que vous préférez dans la
musique
j'aime tous les types de musique
il suffit d'écouter vous savez
pour pouvoir apprécier la différence
type de musique au moins
insulter personne mais je pense que la
musique c'est le plus grand des arts
c'est le plus universel en tous les cas
qu'est-ce que vous n'aimez pas dans la
musique
je pense que la seule chose que je
n'aime pas dans la musique
avec
le plus cher des saloperies mais
j'apprécie tout type de musique qui
comporte un sentiment qui a un sens peu
importe son origine mais ce n'est pas
des choses sales dans la musique
Ray Charles ce qu'elle a été le plus
grand moment de votre vie oh my Gonesse
oh mon dieu
je ne pense pas pour voir
une chose à dire voilà
peut-être la chose la plus grande qui
m'est arrivé c'est lorsque j'ai joué
pour la première fois à Cannes
le pire moment de votre vie
tout à l'heure
quand je dormais à l'extérieur grâce à
Dieu que j'habitais en Floride donc je
pouvais dormir à l'extérieur et à
l'époque où je n'avais rien à manger
où il fallait survivre
peut-être avec quelques haricots secs
des sardines comme vous avez dit donc je
dirais
si vous voulez choisir le pire moment
dans ma vie je dois dire que c'était la
morale de ma mère
c'était le moment le plus
dramatique
mais je pense que la mort de ma mère
c'était le pire
qu'elle a été Ray Charles votre plus
belle histoire d'amour
non
j'étais heureux de faire ce que je
faisais lorsque je le faisais si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
et votre plus minable histoire d'amour
votre pire histoire d'amour
[Musique]
je ne crois pas que j'ai jamais eu
quelque chose de ce genre ma vie ne
s'est pas déroulée comme ça réellement
dernière question Ray Charles que
préférez-vous dans le sexe
je dirais tout simplement venez et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu